willkommen zur heutigen sitzung in der
wir uns im ausgang von der letzten
sitzung in der wir es mit dem thema
transformers zu tun hatte ich nach oben
rechts in lync rhein mit einer
prominenten neueren kritik befassen
werden die die thesen des trans
humanismus
ethisch moralphilosophie problematisiert
ich gebe hier nochmal kurzen rückblick
den transformers muss wir hatten da ein
buch diskutiert dem titel sing clarity
ist er freundlich jungens trends and
biology von ray kurzweil im
kalifornischen
ingenieuren taucha futurologen man sich
nicht sicher wie man ihn
beschreiben soll ist es ein philosoph
vielleicht teilweise futurologen
zukunftsdenken pionier denker wäre
vielleicht noch ein besserer bessere
bezeichnung als ein grandioser ingenieur
der bedeutende erfindung gemacht hat der
aber natürlich dann auch sich weitere
gedanken gemacht hat über
die bloßen erfindungen hinaus nämlich
wohin könnte die ganze entwicklung
führen hat also die bisherigen
entwicklung auf eine ganz konsequente
weise weiter gedacht man muss sich nur
fragen ist dieses weiterdenken aus
philosophischer sicht
überzeugend aus
wissenschaftlicher
naturwissenschaftlicher sich sicherlich
spannend anregend aber auch da
problematisch dann geht es häufig auch
so ein bisschen diese literarische
gattung hindernis science fiction
thriller liest sich fast wie so ein
zukunftsroman
also ganz spannend und hier ist dann die
bereits besagte
singularität kurve die durch
exponentielles wachstum erzielt wird
irgendwann in der zukunft ist die
konkrete entwicklung der rechenoperation
so steil dass etwas neues energien das
vielleicht maschinen denken können dass
wir menschen wie biologische menschen
mit der technik verschmelzen und in
einer allerletzten entwicklungs
evolutionsstufe es gibt ja verschiedene
stufen der evolution sogar unsere
intelligenz von unserem körper lösen
können als software und in letzter
konsequenz im ganzen universum
verbreiten können das ist also
vielleicht die aller konsequenz ist
ausgestaltung der idee des transfers
muss wir verlassen die erde wir
bevölkern durch unser denken das ganze
universum das ist der transfer mannis
muss auf die spitze getrieben jetzt
gibt's natürlich reaktionen darauf und
eine dieser reaktionen diesen kritischen
reaktionen möchte ich heute vorstellen
von julian nida-rümelin und natalie
beiden fällt julia wiederholung ist ein
professor für
politische philosophie an der lmu
münchen das buch hat entwickelt digitale
organismus eine ethik für das zeitalter
der künstlichen intelligenz
wie das titelbild zeigt es geht um
roboter es geht um die frage wie wir sie
wie wir diese entwicklungen ethisch
bewerten sollen und wir haben verleiht
fragen worin besteht die silicon valley
ideologie das ist eine bezeichnung die
wir auch in diesem buch finden die den
trans mannis muss kritisiert und wenn es
diese silicon valley ideologie
problematisch ethisch problematisch
warum können roboter keine moralischen
urteilskraft besitzen nach auffassung
dieser autoren warum kann kann überhaupt
nicht denken auch nach dieser auffassung
wir haben uns damit stand fest mit
kaffee und der frage ob sie denken
könnte nach oben rechts und links zu der
sitzung wo wir es mit neuronalen netzen
zu tun hatten die sache ist sehr
kompliziert es hängt natürlich immer
davon ab was man unter denken versteht
sie zitiere hier ein paar
textstellen die mir sehr zentral zu sein
scheinen die autoren schreiben
möglicherweise wird man in einer fernen
zukunft auf die menschheitsgeschichte
zurückblicken und von drei großen
disruptiven technologischen innovation
sprechen übergang von der jäger und
sammler kultur zu sesshaften agrarkultur
mit ackerbau und viehzucht in der
jungsteinzeit
übergang zu maschinen zeitalter auf der
grundlage von vieler energieträger im 21
jahrhundert und schließt die digitale
revolution des 21 die nutzung
künstlicher intelligenz wie kann man
sich jetzt natürlich fragen ob wenn es
eine digitale revolution gibt ob die
wirklich nur auf künstliche intelligenz
zu reduzieren ist stellt sich wieder die
frage was ist überhaupt künstlichen
trinkens sollte dies einmal so sein dann
stehen wir heute erst am anfang an der
technologischen revolution ähnlich wie
europa in den ersten jahrzehnten des 19
jahrhunderts und so wie damals sind die
technologischen neuerungen auch heute
von apokalyptischen ängsten aber auch
euphorischen erwartungen begleitet sie
sehen schon der
digitale humanismus versucht eine
mittlere position einzuschlagen möchte
nicht
apokalyptische ängste schüren angesichts
dieser neuen
disruptiven entwicklung aber auch keine
euphorischen erwartungen wecken möchte
einen gesunden mittelweg gehen und das
ist so diese anlage jetzt kommt die
beschreibung des buches dieses buch
befasst sich mit kulturellen und
philosophischen aspekten der künstlichen
genc und plädiert für einen digital
humanismus dieses technik aber auch
menschenfreundlich dann setz dich von
apocalyptica ab weil er der menschen
vertraut und er setzt sich vor dem
hurrikan ab weil er die grenzen
digitaler technik achtet hier haben wir
jetzt diese kritische mittelposition er
ist technik aber auch menschenfreundlich
also bei aller technischen euphorie
dürfen wir so dieser humanismus da
steckt ja auch humanus drin menschlich
dürfen wir den menschen nicht verkehrt
wir müssen also technik und
menschenfreundlich sein
politiker die das ende der menschheit
durch die übernahme der roboter
befürchten tritt der digital humanismus
entgegen weil er der menschen vertraut
und den
rittern denen die glauben damit sei
jetzt plötzlich alles möglich da gehört
natürlich ray kurzweil dazu
da
hat er auch kritische
einreden weil nämlich die grenzen der
digitalen technik noch ernster genommen
werden das ist so die perspektive
von dieser digitalen humanistischen
strategie weiter geht es kann kein
zweifel bestehen wir leben in einer zeit
des technologischen umbruchs dieses und
das nächste jahr 100 davon sind viele
überzeugt werden das zeitalter sein in
dem roboter viele arten menschlicher
arbeit übernehmen sieht roboter geben
die pakete aussagen taxifahren sich als
bankberater betätigen dem weltraum
erkunden in calls sind dann arbeit neben
ärzten krankenhäusern operieren und
möglicherweise auch romane schreiben
oder sich anderweitig als künstler
betätigen die digitalisierung hat schon
heute unsere arbeitswelt aber auch
unsere privaten lebens werden
durchdrungen und übt einen gewaltigen
für ein luchs druck auf die ökonomischen
und sozialen verhältnisse dies wird
viele fragen auf da dem es ohne frage
zuzustimmen die digitalisierung ist ein
wie wir gesehen haben pervasive das
phänomen sie trinkt in ganze schöne
lebensweise lebenswelten ein
berufswelten ein und sie verändert und
was die freunde ist jetzt eben nur wie
verändert sie genau diese
lebensverhältnisse und jetzt kommt die
these des buches wie entwickeln diese
buch die grundzüge eines digitalen
humanismus als alternative zu dem was
man etwas vereinfachend als silicon
valley ideologie bezahlten kann diese
ideologie zur die autoren hängt mit der
uramerikanische puritanisch geprägt
lösung forschung zusammen eine welt der
rhein und gerechten zu schaffen die
schmutz und zünde hinter sich gelassen
haben
ähnlich dem prediger schon winthrop der
in seiner berühmten radio city ab ohne
hirn statt auf einem hügel im jahr 1630
den puritanischen zittern guten hoffnung
machen wollte indem er sie auf ihre
sonderstellung und die herausragende
bedeutung der besiedlung für den rest
der welt hinwies wir könnten viele
software ingenieure aus zuletzt ihre
auserwähltheit und die einzigartige
fähigkeiten ihres arbeitsplatzes an dem
dinge entstehen die für den rest der
menschheit wichtig sind zitate people
big valley engineers and business day
allerdings partie hätte real believe
glaube
der tuning world of creative people of
most auf junge kainz problem hall
beliebte warnatzsch das ist ein zitat
eines silicon valley ideologen muss man
sich fragen silicon valley und die
arbeit an kai wird damit metaphysisch
aufgeladen sie bedeutet nicht nur
business sie ist auch eine glaubensfrage
dem sicherlich zustimmt denken sie an
ihren maske und die anderen jahren
pioniere die sicherlich nicht nur bei
ihrer technologie bleiben sondern die
darüber hinaus auch aussagen treffen die
man durchaus
metaphysischen könnte metaphysisch
bedeutet sie sind nicht mehr durch die
erfahrung durch die naturwissenschaft
gedeckt sie betreffen ja erste und
letzte fragen wohin entwickeln wir uns
überhaupt was ist der sinn der technik
überhaupt es sind metaphysische sparen
und da sagt jetzt zu lernen wird die
silicon valley ideologie problematisch
auch ethisch die zentralen werte dieses
glaubens diese ideologie sind
transparenz und berechenbarkeit
ökonomische erfolgt und mit zehn
ethisches engagement als in den zähnen
tum ist diese spender mentalität die
voerder mentalität die eben reichen
menschen häufig eigenes usa eben auch
dass da reiche menschen was ja sehr
positiv empfunden um ist eben auch sehr
viel geld spenden für bestimmte zeige in
zeiten der digitalisierung bringen sie
perfekt konstruierte gegenüber hervor
software identitäten deren konstruktion
jeden fehler ausschließt und die uns als
partner technologisches utopia für der
schlüsselbegriff dabei ist der
künstliche intelligenz aufgeladen mit
unausgesprochener metaphysik und
theologie eine sich selbst verbesserte
hyper rationale zunehmend beseelte
entität deren chips allerdings nicht
gott oder götter sitzungen software
ingenieur
der sich selbst nicht lediglich als teil
einer industrie verstehen sondern einer
übergreifenden geistigen bewegung wie es
reid hoffman formuliert silicon valley
ist mein set the location da die mir
sicherlich auch zuzustimmen das silicon
valley ist zum inbegriff einer
geisteshaltung geworden es ist nicht nur
eine topologische geografische
bezeichnung sondern es ist der inbegriff
für ein fortschrittsdenken was ja
durchaus auch spekulative züge annimmt
und darin sicherlich auch die grenzen
überschreitet insofern ist diese
anliegen der autoren hier erstmal sehr
zu zerstören die silicon valley
ideologie nimmt humanistische impulse
als ausgangspunkt um sie dann nicht zum
ersten mal der kulturgeschichte der
menschheit zu anti humanistischen utopie
zu transformieren sie beginnt bei der
verbesserung des humanen und endet in
seiner finalen überwindung sie will dass
menschen ihr leben auf dem planeten
verbessern und stellt die bedingungen
von humanität in frage zugeführt den
transformers muss zu den humanismus zum
transit mannis muss und zur
technizistischen utopie in der das
menschliche auf der strecke bleibt dem
stellt sich der digital humanismus als
eine ethik für das zeitalter der künste
intelligenz entgegen das kann man sich
fragen ja worin besteht denn jetzt denn
genau
diese überschreitung der menschlichen
grenzen ja worin besteht denn jetzt hier
das auf der strecke bleiben des
menschlichen die traditionalisten könnte
noch sagen es ist doch gerade menschlich
dich selbst zu überschreiten wir sind
doch nur humanisten eben die aller
konsequentesten humanisten weil wir das
beste für den menschen wollen und das
ist die verschmelzung mit seiner technik
die ja auch nur ein mensch ist
könnt ihr jetzt hier der autor sagen der
kritiker der silicon valley theologie ja
aber er tut den menschen gewalt an weil
ihr allen menschen das diktiert diese
transformation vielleicht wollen
menschen damit maschine
verschmelzen ja vielleicht werden
menschen dadurch nur vergeben ständig zu
technischen objekten zur software wenn
man ihn auch den leib nimm das ist ja
ein großer
einschnitt in die individuelle freiheit
unser körper unser leib genauer gesagt
unser beliebter körper ist doch auch ein
teil von uns er macht auch ein teil
unserer identität aus nicht nur unser
denken macht unsere identität aus auch
unser körper könnte man dagegen
einwenden die trans müssten würden sagen
nein der körper der leib der körper
besser gesagt ist nur eine hülle die wir
hinter uns lassen müssen
die uns beschränkt die uns an weiteren
transnistrischen der kinder hatte k s
und jetzt kommt die nächste frage die
dieses thema denken und roboter betrifft
also nach dieser these des digitalen
organismus können natürlich roboter
nicht denken und handeln nämlich das
argument die aks handeln nicht nach
eigenen drücken sie haben keine gefühle
kein moralisches würden keine intention
und sie können diese anderen personen
auch nicht zu schreiben ohne diese
fähigkeiten aber ist eine angemessene
moralische praxis nicht möglich wo eine
berechtigte von einer unberechtigten
bitte unterscheiden zu können ist es
erforderlich die bitten der person
richtig einzuschätzen ihre motive zu
erkennen und ihre interessen zu
berücksichtigen auch die besonderen
verpflichtungen gegenüber nahestehenden
lassen sich nur auf grundlage geteilter
internationalität und geteilte emotionen
bestimmt selbst das motiv des
wohlwollens setzt ein gewisses maß an
empathie voraus die fähigkeit die in die
empfindung lagen an ein nein zu
versetzen ist eben entscheiden da ein
computer nicht über qualia also
subjektive zustände wie bewusst sein
selbstbewusstsein gefühle verfügt so
jedenfalls die autoren gehen ihm die
entscheidenden zutaten moralischen
urteilskraft
er verfügt nicht über moralischen
urteilskraft sondern könnte diese
allenfalls simuliert es geht als um die
frage wird hier nur was simuliert oder
wird hier das wirklich realisieren das
ist die entscheidende frage und man kann
jetzt hier so ein bisschen kritisch ein
werden gegenüber diese kritik dass doch
diese ganzen phänomene verdienen hier
die rede ist also dass man andere person
einschätzt dass man eine berechtigte von
unberechtigten bitte unterscheidet dass
man das doch alles also ein muster
ansehen kann also eine künstliche
intelligenz wenn sie nur genug muster
erlernt hat auf basis der lebenswelt
könnte durchaus so meine these
berechtigte für unberechtigt
unterscheiden können nämlich weise die
muster berechtigter bitten verinnerlicht
haben das würde natürlich eine
unglaubliche form von emotionaler
intelligenz erfordern emotionaler
datenbasen hat man könnte das durchaus
realisieren die frage natürlich nur ob
man damit dann sagen würde dass diese
künstler intelligenz auch quali er hat
das sicherlich nicht aber man kann viele
dieser dinge
auch verpflichtungen im sinne von
mustern verstehen und die eben ein
trainiert das scheint mir durchaus
möglich zu sein also es ist nicht so
einfach dass man es nur als simulation
ansieht sondern wenn man davon ausgeht
es handelt sich wusste dann kann eine
kali diese musste gesetzt den fall sind
genug empirische darf auch verinnerlicht
angenommen so weiter dieser text eine
optimierungs kalkül könnte eine solche
simulation ermöglichen hoffentlich
ästhetische programm würde man
zurückgreifen die beiden bis heute
dominierenden paradigmen der ethik
orientieren sich entweder ein klassisch
mit vitalis muss der darauf ausgerichtet
ist seine handlung so zu wählen dass sie
die besten folgen daraus entstehen oder
am kategorischen imperativ immanuel kant
der verlangt die eigenen handlungsmotive
die maximen auf ihre frage meiner bank
überprüfen handel es so dass die maxime
deines handelns genau gesagt die maxime
deines willens
zum prinzip alle einer allgemeinen
gesetzgebung wir haben könnte welches
der behalten ist zum standpunkt des
digitalen mannis muss aus gesehen das
richtige die antwort lautet keines von
beiden da sowohl das unterlid
artistische wieder das kannte städte
angesichts der komplexität ethischer
delegationen der vibrationen sind die
überlegung die abwägung hoffnungslos
überfordert ist ja also wenn man jetzt
schon muster integrieren könnte soziale
muster ethische muster in dieser kann
dann muss man natürlich immer zwar auf
basis von welchen paradigma lse von
welchen von michael tischen groß theorie
machten das geht es wenn man die muster
für in licht um die konsequenzen oder
geht es um die beschaffenheit des
willens der maxime ihre grundsätze
angeht es nicht um die konsequenzen die
prinzipien sondern die ki auf
konsequenzen hin trainieren oder auf
prinzipien natürlich kann man sagen auch
konsequenzen sind musste im prinzipien
sind auch muster also man könnte sich
irgendwie einmischung muster überlegen
was natürlich immer noch problematisch
ist weil wer bestimmt nach welchen
paradigma die ki trainiert das ist
sicherlich eine sehr berechtigte frage
ja es gibt in der tat die verbreitete
auffassung dass mit der einführung
künstlicher neuronaler netze in der
computertechnologie die festschreibung
von computern als touring maschinen
bewundern
das war diese frage nach der
symbolischen calais
die eben ja regel passiert operiert dann
mache ich auch oben rechts und links zu
dieser sitzung
und wo eben nur der druck tief
gewissermaßen von oben nach unten also
top bottom mäßig operiert wird das sagt
jetzt die niederinnen ist jedoch ein
irrtum sowohl die top down methode der
rechenprozesse computation des der
symbolische ansatz als auch die bottom
up methoden christi von unten nach oben
das ist die methode der künstlichen
neuronalen netze
diese methode selbst der einen systeme
sind von algorithmen geleitet auch bei
selbst ein system muss vorab feststehen
welche resultat erwünscht sind um den
lernprozess des computers in gang setzen
ziel ist es die gewünschten ergebnisse
aufgrund bestimmter eingabedaten zu
erreichen ein beispiel sind die schon
recht weit gediehen softwaresysteme zu
gesicht es ist sicherlich richtig dass
auch künstliche neuronale netze durch
algorithmen gestopft werden muss man
hier zwei dinge noch mal betonen einmal
es geht eben immer gute datenbasis und
die datenbasis selbst die kann
prinzipiell
nicht absehbar seien die kann sich immer
wieder aktualisieren in die datenbasis
gehen wir selbst ein die datenbasis
bestimmen und prägen wir aktiv selbst
wenn sie nur weit genug gefasst wird und
die datenbasis verändert sich auch
ständig das heißt wir haben sicherlich
einmal algorithmen aber die operieren
auf elterlichen daten passen und
weiterer punkt ist die algorithmen
können sich auch selbst verändern weil
das system sich selbst auf sich bezieht
so das ist so deterministisch auch
wiederum nicht ist wie jetzt die autoren
hier behaupten also es hat auch eine
ganz deutliche
flexibilität des neuronalen netz
gegenüber diesen blues symbolischen
ansatz der induktiv von oben nach unten
erfährt von den regeln prinzipien zur
konkreten anwendung ja das war jetzt so
eine kurze einblick in den digitalen und
man dieses der sich als ein typisch
mittelweg zwischen euphorie kann und
apocalyptica versteht ich würde kritisch
ein bisschen anmerken dass er vielleicht
die neueren entwicklung zu sehr
reduziert also tendenziell reduktion ist
ist und so was wie virtuelle realität
die im agiert auf diesen medien die
nicht mehr nur im sinne von simulationen
zu verstehen wie es vielleicht etwas
nicht ernst genug nimmt aber prinzipiell
ist natürlich immer sehr sinnvoll die
menschliche würde bei allen technischen
entwicklung zu behaupten aber ich würde
trotzdem sagen technische entwicklung
und menschliche würde schließen sich
nicht aus sondern
kann sie aufeinander beziehen kann die
technik sogar als eine erweiterung oder
als eine beförderung der menschlichen
würde verstehen setzt natürlich immer
voraus dass man den menschen dadurch
keine gewalt antut und sie nicht
zwangsbeglückt dem man sie mit
technologie gefordert oder sogar auch am
ende zur bloßen objekten macht das heißt
jeder mensch muss immer autonom selbst
mitbestimmen was mit ihm und der technik
geschieht das ist vielleicht ganz
wichtig und dann kann man vielleicht
auch die technologischen entwicklungen
sich virtuelle realität noch ein
bisschen ernster nehmen als es die
autoren dieses buches tun in der
nächsten sitzung werden wir uns mit dem
thema ethik der computerspiele befassen
dass es deswegen ganz spannendes thema
weil computerspiele als teil phänomen
der digitalisierung immer mehr in unsere
lebenswelt eingang finden
computerspielen ist nicht mehr nur so
eine beschäftigung von nerds die das
nachts machen und sich abschotten in
ihrem stillen kämmerlein sondern
computerspiele werden gesellschaftsfähig
sie gehen ein in verschiedene praktiken
unseres alltags sie gehen einen das
lehren und lernen stichwort gaming
fiction
sie gehen aber auch ein in
internationale interdisziplinäre aber
auch in der subjektive praktiken dass
wir uns im computerspielen mit menschen
aus der ganzen welt vernetzen und mit
ihnen darüber kommunizieren also
computerspiel als form der kommunikation
das ist noch ein wichtiger punkt und ein
letzter auf den es mit einem besonders
ankommen wird computerspielen ist nicht
nur eine sinnlose spielerei eine
banalität eine
zeitverschwendung oder eine zeit der
zeitvertreib ein ernstes anliegen
sondern computerspielen können wir als
form philosophischen reflexionen
verstehen weil die in computerspielen
uns mit den optionen dem dimensionen den
modalitäten von möglichkeit von fiktion
simulation von virtuelle realität von
realität befassen also im computerspiel
etablieren wie einen welt bezug und
flüchten nicht vor der wand das ist so
glaube ich eine andere perspektive die
sie immer weiter zeigt also meine these
und darüber wird man nächsten sitzung
diskutiert computerspielen kann bedeuten
muss nicht kann bedeuten auch zu
reflektieren kann bedeuten moralische
probleme zu reflektieren kann bedeuten
am ende selbst zu philosophieren und
kann auch selbst ein bildungsprozess
bedeuten dass wir uns im computerspiel
selbst weiterentwickeln weil wir auch
uns selbst dadurch am ende besser
kennenlernen das ist ein kurzer ausblick
dann bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit
und bis zur nächsten sitzung